أجنبي ،
سعيد جدًا برؤيتكم اليوم ،
يسعدنا جدًا رؤيتكم أيضًا ،
فأنتم ترتدون ملابس مثل la casa de papel
في مرتفعات المال ،
شكرًا بالضبط لملاحظة
نعم
[ضحك]
أنك محاط بذلك بالطبع
أنت "  ستلاحظ أن هذا هو الشيء الوحيد
الذي ستعرفه عنك ولم تتمكن من
ملاحظة
نعم ، نعم ، شكرًا لك ، نحن سعداء جدًا
برؤيتكم يا رفاق ، كيف تشعر
أنك وصلت إلى النهاية
في واقع الأمر اليوم هو نهاية
اليوم  هي نهاية اليوم الأخير ،
لذا ، نعم ، نعم
جيد جدًا ،
عاطفي ، من الجيد جدًا أن أرى
الأصدقاء الذين تعرفهم ، لن أقول
الممثلين المشاركين والأصدقاء أننا
أصبحنا العائلة التي أصبحنا
أه نقضي وقتًا ممتعًا معها
رائع ،
نحن لم نعمل معًا ، لا لم يكن
لدينا مشهد واحد معًا ،
هذا هو أول مشهد لنا معًا ، إنه
مثل فيلم ، نعم قضاء الوقت معًا ،
لقد كان جيدًا ،
لكنك تعلم نعم ولكن في
نهاية اليوم
معًا
نعم
في نهاية اليوم أعتقد أنه
مزيج من المشاعر
يريح العمل الذي تم إجراؤه بشكل جيد
والنتيجة
متحمسة لمعرفة كيف
سيتلقى الجمهور ذلك والنتيجة العاطفية والحزينة
لأنك تعلم
أننا سنأخذ أدوارًا مختلفة وسنظل على اتصال
ولكن الأمر لن يكون هو نفسه
لكنك تعلم أن هناك كل هذه
المشاعر مجتمعة بالنسبة لي ،
لكنك ستظل دائمًا ارتورو بالنسبة لنا ،
هه
لا سيكون ، سأكون دائمًا
إنريكي ، سأكون
دائمًا كما تعلم ، يمكنني أن أكون أيًا
كان
اسمها فقط اسمها
هو  الكراك هذا رائع ،
فقط سمي
أنك كنت على الجانب الآخر كنت
مع الرجال الآخرين ، ما رأيك في
إنريكي أو أورتورو ،
أنا أكره أرتورو ، حسنًا ، أريد أن أحب أه
مثل الشخصية التي هي الغرض
من الشخصية ، حسنًا
هو يقول مثل  إنه شيء يتعلق
بالحب والكراهية بالنسبة لي ، إنه مجرد
كره نقي
اليوم هو
اليوم الأول
ربما نتحدث كما لو أنني لا أعرف خمس
دقائق تدخن سيجارة
على المجموعة مثل مرتين مع ثلاث
لكنهم أخبروني بالأمس حسنًا ، ستذهب
للقيام بكل المهملات مع اه إنريكي
أوكا  دعنا نذهب ، لقد
كان
رائعًا ويبدو الأمر كما لو كان رائعًا ، لذلك
أنا أحب
إنريكي ، أكره ، أريد أن أقتل
أرتورو وأحب هذا الرجل ، نعم الأمر مختلف
بالنسبة لي ، أحب أرتورو وأكره إنريكي
ولكن علي التحدث إلى طبيبي النفسي
حول ذلك ، ستكون إجابة طويلة ،
أنا متأكد من أنك تتلقى الكثير من
التعليقات السلبية بسبب التهديدات بالقتل بالقتل في Arturo ،
لكنك تعلم ما كان
سيئًا للغاية في الموسم الأول والثاني ، ثم
لسبب ما ،  أعتقد أن الناس
اعتادوا على أرتورو وقد تضاءل ،
لكن الأمر أصبح مخيفًا حقًا في مرحلة ما
كنت مثل الرجال ، هذا خيال من
أجل الله ، نعم أنت تعرف لماذا أنا لست
أرتورو ، أنا إنريكي ، لماذا عليك أن
تهددني بالإهانة  أنا ولكن هذا جزء من
وسائل الإعلام والعالم الذي نعيشه اليوم
،
استخدم الناس وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي كإفراج
عن مشاعرهم من ضغوطهم
بسبب المزاج السيئ وأعتقد أنني حصلت على الشخص
الذي حصل على اللكمات لذلك لذا نعم
يمكنني  اعتبر نعم ، أعتقد أننا جميعًا أردنا لكمك
أو هل هذا ما تريد القيام به
هنا
هل تعلم أنه بسبب Arturo 19 تم إطلاق
سراح الرهائن في الموسم الأول
نعم نحن نعلم أن حياتك أفضل من
واحد ولا أنت لم تكن السبب
ولا حاولت أن تجعلها
كما حاولت  لاستخدام حيلك
حتى لا تعمل ، لذا لا لا لا
أرتورو نحن نعلم أنك هنا
[ضحك]
نحن بالفعل نقاتل نحن بالفعل
بخير
أنا آسف ولكن
اسمحوا لي أن أسألكم يا رفاق عن شيء آخر
لذلك  يحظى العرض بشعبية كبيرة ولكن
هناك الكثير من النقاش والكثير
من الانتقادات
حول العرض الذي يمجد العنف
وفي الواقع يظهرون أه جريمة تمجيد
على سبيل المثال ، يقول بعض الأشخاص الآخرين
أوه لا هناك روبن هود الجديد
ما رأيك في هذه المناقشة
يا
[موسيقى]
أنا آسف جدًا ولكني واضح جدًا في العادة
مع إجاباتي ، فإن
لغتي الإنجليزية ليست جيدة جدًا ، لكنني سأكون
واضحًا جدًا ،
لا إذا أردنا
استخدام سماعات الرأس
لاحقًا ، فالعالم مكان عنيف ،
حسنًا
وهو عنف يتم وضعه في
خدمة g  لقد أوضح الأستاذ في
الموسم الأول تمامًا أنه لا
يجب أن يموت أحد ، الأشخاص الوحيدون الذين يموتون
هم الأشخاص الموجودون في الخلف يقاتلون الشرطة
ولكن في كل فيلم هناك أشخاص
يقاتلون الشرطة ، هذا
جزء من الخيال آسف  حسنًا ، لا يمكنك
محاربة شرطة
الشرطة دائمًا هنا
ولكني أقاتل مع أي شخص أعتقد
أنه ضد هذه مناقشة كبيرة
لكني أحب إصدار روبن هود الحديث
الذي قلته أعتقد بطريقة ما أنه
يشبه ذلك قليلاً
هل أنتم متفاجئون يا رفاق
بشعبية البرنامج في العالم العربي ،
نعم كثيرًا ، أعني
ليس فقط في العالم العربي ، أعني
أننا مخادعون صغيرون لدينا بلد كبير
ولكننا دولة صغيرة
وهذا العرض  إنه مخصص جدًا
للجماهير الإسبانية ،
لذا فإن حقيقة أن
الكثير من الإزعاج لطريقة الحياة الإسبانية
وطريقة الحديث التي تم
تصويرها في العرض
بالنسبة لي يذهلني أنه
يسافر إلى المملكة العربية السعودية إلى الفلبين
إلى إندونيسيا إلى الأرجنتين
أنت تعلم أنه من الجنون جدًا كيف يمكننا
التواصل مع شيء
أصلي جدًا من بلدنا
كان قادرًا على السفر
كثيرًا وهذا يخبرك أنه عندما يكون
هناك عرض جيد ، فإن الخيال
والدراما جيدة أه تعرف الكلمات  لا
معنى لها
وأنت تعلم
أنه أمر لا يصدق ، أنت تعرف
عدد الأشخاص الذين يخبرونني من بلدك
أو من الهند أو من دول
أخرى أنهم يشاهدون العرض في الإصدار الأصلي
الذي يتعلمون فيه اللغة الإسبانية
وقد أخبرني الكثير من الناس أنني تعلمت
الإسبانية من la casa papel خاصةً
من البلدان القريبة جدًا منا
مثل إيطاليا ، نحن لا نصنع
خيالًا فحسب ،
فنحن نعلم أننا نعطي العالم الكثير
من الأشياء أكثر من ذلك ، وأعتقد أن هذا
تأثير عالمي عظيم على أي حال يا
رفاق  أريد أن تأخذ المزيد من وقتك ،
أعلم أن لديك الكثير من المقابلات
لأستمتع بها وأحب التحدث إليكم يا
رفاق وأنتم يا رفاق تصنعون زوجًا رائعًا معًا ،
يجب أن نقدم عرضًا معًا نعم أعتقد
صافي  فليكس يشاهد ، هيا ، ضعنا
معًا ،
إنه ممتع كثيرًا ،
شكرًا لك ، شكرًا لك ، سأغفر لأرتورو
بعد أن قلت إنني جميل
عشر دقائق فقط ، استغرق الأمر مني عشر دقائق فقط ،
يمكنك أن ترى ما يمكنني
فعله طوال اليوم
شكرًا لكم يا رفاق ، شكرًا لكم يا رفاق ، شكرًا لكم
على العرض الرائع وعلى كل شيء ،
شكرًا لكم ، شكرًا وداعًا
واليوم
[موسيقى]
لكم